Tom Curren covers the Patriots and he
joins us now
Tom how's morale today oh the Whelan is
down the wing mode is panic the wing
with is freaking out which is what New
England is prone to do wait are you
being facetious oh you really think that
there's there's panic in Boston there's
a level of resignation among Patriots
fans are not resignation but sky is
chicken little
that goes on where the one cloud that
passes through and otherwise perfectly
blue sky is just the sign that the
Hurricanes coming well I think that 2015
season Dan with the Patriots lost for
the last six including in the playoffs
as well and in Denver that left a dent
and last night's game looked like that
stretch at the end of 2015
what would concern you the rest of the
regular season is certainly going into
next week's game with Pittsburgh you
know there were so many factors that
went into last night I think it would be
teams playing that press coverage on the
outside and getting pressure on Brady
and I think that that Miami having
played them two weeks before said you
know what we're not gonna do what we did
last week we're gonna do this and I got
pressure you know the Patriots are not
really stout they're gonna big guys in
the middle and I think that Sue and some
of the other players got some pressure
in the middle on Brady that didn't allow
him to step up as he's been doing all
year and really they're outside
receivers and this is one of the reasons
it was really damaging to lose Edelman
is they don't have that unbelievable
sudden quickness to get separation cooks
is awesome as a downfield receiver but
he doesn't have that kind of quick
nuance where he can get freaky and I
think you saw that last night Brady was
one for seven throwing to him for just a
late 38 yarder the national criticism
today it feels like it's a little bit of
piling on with Brady hot takes that
maybe starting to show his age the last
three games haven't been very good the
first 10 were MVP like but the last
three what do you make of that
you have to look a little bit past his
statistics and look at the statistics of
the team in the two previous games they
ran for almost 200 yards so they were in
for 196 against Miami and 198 I think
against Buffalo so they weren't throwing
the ball a lot and they were having
great success with that against against
Buffalo they came out in the second half
after being tight with the bills and
they just hammered it to Grunk who's
actually having his one of his best
years I think and the Buffalo game was
one of his most dominant games I think
I've ever seen him play especially in
the second half until he lost his mind
so I think that that would be
overstating it and just it was a 28 year
old no one would say that yeah just
trying to figure out you know you get
Gronk back against Pittsburgh but it's
in Pittsburgh
how does Bella check make this a
positive which he seems to he's able to
do this somehow some way that now will
get a good Patriots performance after
what we didn't get last night
I think Gronk comes back what we saw
from Pittsburgh the other days a loss of
Ryan shazier is terrible in the
individual level of it and incredibly
damaging to their team because their
speed at the linebacker position is
massive and the Patriots have worked to
try and get those mismatches at the
linebacker level why weren't they able
to do it last night because Miami was
sending extra rushers and they were
getting home with it and they weren't
getting the separation usually when you
send an extra rusher at Brady somebody
is able to uncover but that's not really
a strength of cooks in terms of short
area quickness or for Hogan having Gronk
back will add just a kind of a safety
net and you know you figure it
absolutely Dan casts the game in a
different light now that you've seen the
Patriots allow more than 17 points in
the first time in a while and look
stagnant offensively but I still think
that that was the aberration on Monday
night as opposed to what you would
probably see from them going forward if
I said you
have brady winning one more Super Bowl
in the next three years you had to put
up $1,000 oh oh oh I thought you was
gonna be in either or or Jimmy Garoppolo
wins one in 2020 for the Patriots
I mean that's that's really I mean he
looks so good and I think that there is
a lot of hand-wringing around here about
that and no really a lot of sellers
remorse going on so who wins the Super
Bowl sooner Garoppolo abrading that's
right who ends up with more MVPs yeah
and then Brady has to go home in
retirement watch Jimmy just carry the
San Francisco 49ers in the Bay Area to
play some quarterback to Jim so you did
alright finish this question here if the
Patriots no no I you're gonna go with
Brady that's your boy if the Patriots
lose to the Steelers dot dot dot the
Steelers will still find a way to pee
down their legs before the end of their
season thank you Tom well said I know I
don't want to know the second thing
thank you Tom
that's Tom Curren NBC Sports newing it
covers the Patriots for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]